What's up. It's your boy, DJ Pauly, D and Vinnie G catch our new show,
a double shot at love. But right now we're going to answer the internet.
Um.
Starting today, if you get $10,000 a day for every day, you don't.
How many days could you go without jerking off? Hey,
if I got 10,000 a day.
Every day, you don't. You'll be broke.
Um, I probably could do like, wait so 10,000 what's 10.
I could probably get like 300 grand that's a month. Right?
You can go a month. I could go. If I look on the way over here,
a little bit on me, I'm drinking it right now. I mean,
if I've got 300 grand out of it, I can do it now.
30 Days a week.
All right. You are stuck on a desert Island for a year,
but you can bring one person with you. Who do you pick? Boom.
Um, my mama. Yeah. I was thinking my mom,
but I probably would get horny so.
That we'll meet for 30 days.
Well, there's no money.
Now as far a year. A year. Yeah, but what'd you bring?
Um, one person. I don't know, like, yeah, I guess my mom too.
I'll just wait.
To my answer. Yeah.
Sorry. Come loudly.
Every time you fart or fart loudly. Every time you come.
Yo, if you came loudly every time you fart,
you would've came 19 times on the way over here.
Yeah. Quito part smells like. Yeah.
No idea. I find a lot. No, it lingers.
I'm going to fart loudly. Every time I come.
You get to have sex with the girl of your dreams,
but they hold a press conference after rating your sexual performance.
Do you do it now? Yeah.
I'm fine with it. Nah, breast cancer is about to be lit. Yeah.
I bet we, we we'd do that on Jersey shore. Literally. We got like, Oh,
the sex tapes. I just can't air. Would you rather yourself?
Every time you have an orgasm, what do I get? These ones.
Would you rather straight yourself?
Every time you have an orgasm or get a random every time you talk to
a random, every time you talk to a dude, um.
You want to shoot yourself and go, hell no, you better.
Get a all day. Yeah. He'll have to deal with it.
He can hang his hat on it.
Hang my chain. It Would you rather,
your partner always have a huge Bush or you, or you always have a huge Bush?
Honestly. Oh, I would have to have, I don't want her to have it.
I'm bringing back the Bush. I think I like it. Let me say no, not for me.
I think that I like a woman with a little bit back on her. Yeah.
I like a woman with a little, but a little bit of a Bush.
A little racing Stripe. No, no. I like a Bush. Like some natural,
like primitive. Just like we are animals.
We're all animals. That's why I like it. You've got to
[inaudible] watch seventies porn. That is lit. It is at least tying it up.
Give it a lineup.
If you could push one person down a well, who would it be? They survive,
but are stuck down there.
Good pretense. I don't Trump.
Oh, really? One person down a well who?
Uh, they survivors stuck down there. Oh, Angelina. it.
Thank you.
Your mom and girlfriend switched bodies.
The only way to get them back to normal is to bang. One of them.
Who do you have sex with? My.
My girlfriend, like the body.
She's going to have sex with your girlfriend's body. Your mom's.
Brain. Oh, that's up.
My guys are. I would never have sex with my mom's body. However,
what you just said you did to the brain. So she knows it. Well,
I will never have sex on my mom's body. Um, I will never
Bali. It has to be the body. I mean the,
the brain, you can fake the brain thing. You can be like,
you're sick. You would pick, you would have sex with your mind body.
I took one for the team that was up.
All right.